Wanda! Welcome Home.
Vision residence!
I'm gonna burn this place to the ground
Welcome back everyone it's charlie
welcome to the vision residence won't
you all sit down so we have a brand new
Wanda vision trailer to break down if
you're brand new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get everything
we're doing that new giveaway for the
infinity Saga box set all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave
all your theories about Wanda vision on
the video I know everyone's freaking out
about them doing the twins from the
comics then giving her the comic-book
x-men scarlet witch costume so we'll
explain what's going on there's a ton of
Easter eggs in here for a bunch of huge
Scarlet Witch comic book stories because
they cut this trailer in a very
nonlinear way I'll try to break it down
chronologically as I think it happens
through the episodes so you actually
start with that blue logo the reason why
they do the blue logo that changes from
red is just to give the Disney Plus
stuff its own identity even though it's
Marvel Studios the same people that make
the movies that are making this it's all
the movie actors so just to let you know
that this is a little bit special beyond
what you would normally expect
you probably recognize the soundtrack
that they opened the trailer with is
actually the theme song of the Winter
Soldier from Captain America Winter
Soldier so obviously they're going to bring
that back during the Falcon Winter
Soldier episodes don't worry I'll do a
separate trailer breakdown for all the
Falcon Winter Soldier stuff that's
completely separate from what's going on
on the wan division series but then you
hear the doorbell ring and you see
visions face and he says Wanda welcome
home and she just completely
flabbergasted like what the hell is
going on here so this is the way I think
it actually goes down during Wanda
vision episode one so you start actually
in this scene here with this weird 1950s
looking TV everything's in black and
white in this alternate reality that
she's in but she's still in color and
she's still in her regular street
clothes from present day there's a
version of her on the television that's
also answering the phone as if she's
inside a sitcom on the TV saying vision
residence and she's dressed up like
Donna Reed from a 1950s sitcom TV show
then you see the scene of her looking
like she's being folded into this space
like the perspective is shifting she's
still in color in her normal present-day
street clothes but vision and everything
else about this place is right out of
the 1950s and in black-and-white this is
a huge Doctor Strange easter egg in the
way that they do this I'll talk about
how it connects to Doctor Strange too
but the actual Easter Egg is the way
she's moving when she's entering this
reality and it is an alternate reality
remember how Doctor Strange in the
ancient one would move through different
environments when they were fighting Chi
Silius and his fanatics is the exact
same type of perspective shift when
they're folding different realities into
different planes is very inception II in
that way look at her face when she sees
vision still in her street clothes like
oh my god how can this be real how can
you be alive I watched you die that's
why I think this is the first place that
she comes into when she's in this space
for the first time she doesn't know
what's happening it's like one division
episode one then it seems like what
happens is somehow she gets folded into
this reality and she turns black and
white to just like vision and everything
else and because they're filming this
reality like she's literally living out
her life in a 1950s sitcom they play
through all the beats that you typically
see in people's lives on sitcoms they
formally get married then layer in the
footage she gets pregnant with the twins
from the comics wicken in speed they
shift into the 80s and 90s sitcom
realities then I'll get to that stuff in
a second there's so much to unpack here
there's a ton of comic book Easter eggs
but they're basically shifting through
decades of sitcoms so some of this
probably seems very familiar to you the
1950s vibe in the black-and-white vision
our Easter eggs for two different really
big comic book stories there's Tom
King's vision run where vision created a
fake family for himself in present day
and went to live in the suburbs it was a
very 1950s aesthetic even though that
was happening in present day and then
there was the white vision story from
the older avengers comics when he was
brought back to life but he didn't have
the same mental imprint from Wonder Man
like he did the first time
so he had no emotion no personality he
was just this cold unfeeling robot when
you watch him while he's inside this
black and white 1950s sitcom you
probably sense the meta joke here is
that the characters on those TV shows
and those sitcoms were very bland had
very little personality so they're also
making fun of a lot of the tropes of
sitcoms from the 50s 60s 70s 80s 90s and
so on but however she enters this
alternate reality where this is
happening she eventually shifts reality
into the 60s and 70s gets pregnant with
the twins Wiccan and speed look at how
big her belly is twins will definitely
do that to you look at how the house
changes into something that looks right
out of the Brady Bunch in the 70s the
vision Bunch when she starts looking
around all scared and surprised like
thing is happening and she doesn't know
what's going on is probably something to
do with the twins mutant powers while
they're in her womb maybe just strange
things start happening she can't explain
it and eventually the alternate reality
shifts from the 1970s sitcom into the
1980s and she's given birth she
envisioned her dressed up hilariously
like they're inside the early seasons of
full house and the twins are levitating
their pacifiers telekinetically while
they're in their cribs she's freaking
out because she clearly doesn't
understand how their powers working
doesn't know what's going on the other
really met a full-house joke here too is
if you didn't know Elizabeth Olsen is
actually the younger sister of the Olsen
twins who themselves got their start on
Full House in real life vision in jeans
is the funniest thing I've seen all day
and this looks like it's right out of
the Tom King run with vision dressed up
it almost the exact same outfit then her
reality changes again and she looks like
she's in more of a 90s sitcom Roseanne
vibe just in terms of aesthetic she's
got this very Stern disapproving mom
look on her face like the twins or
toddlers and they just did something
really bad look at all the kids drawings
and stuff on the fridge behind her stuff
that the twins would have made for her
wicked and speed then they finally put
her in a version of the classic Scarlet
Witch x-men comic book costume but it's
designed to look like she's wearing a
Halloween costume because this is a
sitcom based reality that she's living
in and I don't know if this is happening
in the 90s or closer to present-day in
terms of the sitcom timeline but the
really meta aspect of this is that
they're going to explain her greater
chaos magic from the comics her reality
warping powers and officially give her
the Scarlet Witch name no one has ever
called her Scarlet Witch in the Marvel
movies yet they've just called her Wanda
she's going full comic books Scarlet
Witch during one division so the x-men
comic book costume is just a metaphor
for that the aesthetic of the logo kind
of lets you know how the reality changes
jumping forward in decades as she's
living out her major life events
marriage children's so on like she's
flipping channels on a TV flipping
through realities my early theory is
that Agatha Harkness has something to do
with why this is all happening and she's
being played by the Kathryn Hahn
character and even though they don't
appear anywhere in this trailer they're
doing sword from the comics in
explaining how Nick Fury creates the
sword organization using the new space
station we saw during the spider-man far
from home
credit scene it confirms that that was
the sword space station from the comics
Everybody back to work!
Who's got my shoes!
This is Monica Rambeau as an adult we
saw her as a child during the Captain
Marvel movie I don't know if they're
going to give her her comic book powers
during this because she's also going to
appear in the Future movies but she's
also an agent of sword during this kat
dennings character Darcy from the Thor
movies is also featured she's probably
associated with sword somehow to in
Jimmy woo from ant-man and the wasp is
also part of this series but because
he's FBI I'm not totally sure how he
gets involved with the Scarlet Witch
reality-warping but as you can see
that's clearly the Doctor Strange -
connection the Wanda vision finale will
probably directly lead into the
beginning of Doctor Strange - Scarlet
Witch is one of the main characters of
that movie is going to be a huge thor
ragnarok style crossover involving you
guessed it another major Marvel villain
from an alternate reality I've already
done a whole bunch of Doctor Strange two
x-men videos because the twins obviously
have mutant powers they're going to be
laying a lot of track work for actual
x-men characters within the Marvel
Cinematic Universe starting with one
division everybody whisper reverse no
more mutants the only speculation and
scuttlebutt on her children is that
they'll actually find a way to logically
keep them around in the normal version
of reality after the events of the
series so that they can then go on to a
Young Avengers project eventually and if
this sounds a little confusing like wait
a minute how could they get that old
that fast they would take a while for
them to age up look at how this series
jumps through the decades in how the
twins grow up through the course of
these different scenes that you see like
by the time you get to Roseanne a 90s
level sitcom they seem like they've aged
years in the span of a couple episodes
because this is a different alternate
reality the rules for how people age how
time moves it's all very different so
that's how you start one division with
her getting married to vision in the
fake reality that by the end of the
series having fully grown twins that
could then go on to their own eventual
young Avengers series there's a lot of
rumors about them involving Quicksilver
there was some test scenes for kids that
were auditioning to play their children
during the course of the series and
during those audition scenes they
reference their uncle that's talking
about the Quicksilver character but
because they filmed this on sound stages
that were all closed nobody actually had
a chance to see whether or not Aaron
taylor-johnson was ever there filming
scene
but it's totally possible the
Quicksilver does show up during this at
some point dr. strange may have a cameo
in the finale there are six episodes
total and based on the Disney Plus
release scheduled later this year 1
divisions release date will probably be
sometime around the beginning of October
Falcon and Winter Soldier will start in
August in air all of its episodes right
before Wanda vision starts I will do a
trailer video for the Loki stuff and for
Falcon and Winter Soldier so I'll add a
link at the end of the video as soon as
I post those but click here for my brand
new Doctor Strange to x-men video and
click here for new avengers until I
finished that Falcon Winter Soldier
trailer then I'll replace the link thank
you so much for watching
everyone stay awesome. This is the way!